we're going to be taking a deep look at
2024 today we're going to look at all
sorts of new approval polls for both the
democratic and republican side but
before we do that i have to start with a
story that many of you i know will say
david this this can't be this has to be
a low even fox news even the right wing
wouldn't do this would they and yes they
did
fox news hosts are now worried
that the rapidly deca declining gas
prices that we're seeing
might be bad
for local mom and pop gas stations i
know guys i know after
months and months and months of saying
the high gas prices
are the uh end of the of the country
they are joe biden's fault it is
inflation it's ruining everything the
high gas prices are so terrible
now that gas prices have been declining
for about a month and of course they
don't want to give joe biden any credit
for it which by the way i don't think he
deserves but they were blaming biden on
the way up now they're silent
now they're saying you know
these lower gas prices
they might be bad for gas stations
listen to this it is beyond parody let's
uh want him to run again
and the rest probably don't that is
stunning by the way on gas prices i
found it curious i was at a lacrosse
tournament up in wilmington delaware
over the weekend in delaware and
northern maryland regular gas is about
anywhere from 455 to 480 a gallon so the
price is beginning to creep back down it
is it is and the point was made over the
weekend i believe it's the wall street
journal that gas prices are actually
coming back down historically faster
with the price of oil than usual and it
just goes to show you what an incredible
risk uh reward calculation has to happen
on the part of those small independently
owned most of them mom and pop gas
stations it's a struggle for all of them
yep yeah still a long way from 355 a
gallon but you know maybe some movement
in that direction hey they can't find
peace and privacy yeah no guys listen i
mean we really have to now think about
these mom and pop gas stations all of a
sudden prices are coming down this could
really be a bad thing for them so we'll
ask the question of whether that's even
true just as a reminder gas prices
indeed coming down they peaked right
around
really about a month ago right right in
mid-june and have been uh in a
relatively steep decline i mean it is
true that normally as i've told you
before
there's this phenomenon where you see
oil prices go up and then gas prices go
up in parallel but then when oil comes
back down the gas prices only trickle
down at a lower rate and we've seen this
with airfare we've seen this in a lot of
different
areas that are dependent on the oil
price but we're actually seeing a
relatively
rapid decline of gas prices now down to
about 464 from a high of about 503. so
it is true that gas prices are coming
down now the question is is it bad for
the mom and pops is it bad for gas
stations when gas prices are lower which
would imply that it's good for gas
stations when prices are higher now this
is not actually even true and so with
all of these uh um
discussions
first you know we get the claim from fox
first we want to verify the fact our gas
price is even coming down and yes they
are coming down and i've reported that
to you the next question is do the local
gas stations suffer when prices come
down it doesn't really work that way
when when oil prices go up
what you actually sometimes see
is gas stations which make very little
off of gas
try to out-compete competitors
by
really eating some of the price increase
so you will see
the gas stations know okay oil prices
are up the cost we are now paying for
gas is up so we have to raise our retail
price i'm going to try to raise the
price less than my competitor down the
street because i make more money from
the slushies and the peanut m ms and the
ten dollar sunglasses or whatever else
so in fact sometimes higher gas prices
higher gas prices are quite good um for
the oil companies but they are not
necessarily so good for the local gas
stations and uh during higher prices
after expenses gas stations will often
make only five cents a gallon sometimes
even less
and um uh that compares to what is often
like a 15 to 20 cent per gallon profit
for gas stations during more stable gas
prices so
multiple aspects of this the big one is
the hypocrisy they've been pulling their
hair out with the sky is falling type
stuff for a year now about high gas
prices which they say are joe biden's
fault
we get a month of declines in gas prices
now they say oh no
lower gas prices aren't so good for the
mom and pop gas stations what about for
all of the commuters that you've been
talking about for a year
that's the main story the maybe just as
interesting one is that high gas prices
are not particularly good for the mom
and pop gas stations for the reasons
that i just said so it's
it's unbelievable that fox i mean it's
they should be embarrassed that now
they're saying gas prices might be going
down too quickly they might get too low
it's an embarrassment but of course
their followers absolutely love it they
never get any contradictory information
from other networks obviously they
should be saying wait this is a
contradictory message from fox they've
been telling me the higher gas prices
are bad all this time now they're saying
the lower gas prices could be bad what
is bad what is good they're not they're
not going to go through that process and
they will accept what is spoon fed to
them but absurd
hypocrisy from fox news one of our
sponsors is magic spoon the only
breakfast cereal that tastes exactly
like your favorite sugary childhood
cereals but with zero sugar
only four net carbs and 14 grams of
protein so if you're just generally
trying to keep your sugar intake
relatively low like me or if you're
doing low carb if you're doing keto you
can enjoy the sweet nostalgic snack
without the sugar in flavors like cocoa
fruity frosted peanut butter cookies and
cream maple waffle blueberry cinnamon
they've just added honey nut to their
permanent collection i love magic spoon
our whole team does and they've been
supporting the show for years how about
this if you try magic spoon and you
don't think it's amazing like we do
they'll give you your money back because
magic spoon stands behind their product
because it's that good you really can't
tell it apart from the classic cereals
build your own custom variety pack
you'll get five dollars off when you go
to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman the
link is in the description